sports yeah see i was uh i was playing
tennis one day
and uh i hit the ball so hard it landed
up on mount rushmore
yeah now it's a ward on lincoln's face
that's ridiculous and yet it happened
i love it tommy flanagan was one of my
favorite characters
on saturday night live and you can see
john lovitz at the laugh factory at the
tropicana every monday through wednesday
for the next four to six weeks
welcome to the show john lovitz how are
you thank you great great great to be
here
every clip of my son yeah who's that
young guy in that photo right now
well that is 30 30 years ago or more you
know you look fantastic you look relaxed
by the way
i am i've been doing shows at the
all week and uh doing them all this week
and uh i'm at a very good time now
tomorrow night is gonna be extra special
because tomorrow is
my birthday yeah big birthday
celebration i'll be 64.
it's very strange because i feel like
i'm lying talking about lying
i don't feel any different but that's
the way it is
oh hello that's a good looking man right
there
that's a relaxed man right there look i
mean you were on snl from
85 to 90. so many iconic characters
where did the inspiration for some of
these characters come from
uh well back then i was really trying to
make it as an actor and i loved old
movies
so master that's being diamond up was
you know a professor of mine william
needles from college
great actor taught me shakespeare and
john barrymore and john carradine
all the actors with the huge voices you
know and then like the liar was from old
movies from the thin man to be going
yeah that's the ticket and then i i
turned it into a lying
thing that's like 50 pounds and 30 years
ago
and uh with your time with snl your
characters were so legendary i remember
being in school and and i would be like
hey get to know me i was dropping your
lines left and right how does it make it
get to know me
it's amazing to be a part of pop culture
i was blown away
and uh get to know me i remember i went
that was just me i was
totally known and i went up to danny
devito was hosting the show and he had
the movie twins come out
and it was like a hundred million dollar
weekend huge which is like 500 million
dollars today
so i went up to him i go hey danny you
want to get ahead in this business get
to know me
and he goes cute and
and then i wrote it it's ridiculous it's
just a
you know guy full of bluster for you
full of it and those and there's
the people that you worked with i mean
to me those that's the glory days of snl
you have
dana carvey mike myers yourself phil
hartman was on there
do you still stay in touch with guys
like dennis miller and some of the other
crew from back then yeah well
yeah mike i run into one smile but yeah
dennis and dana are
two of my best friends and yeah i talked
to them all times just
just saw dennis just played golf with
him a couple weekends ago and
they're all doing great you know and
it's yeah it's kind of like you have
that
whatever group you're and you have that
time together like sandler and all those
guys
but he was adam sandler was there with
you know starting with
chris farley and spade and chris rock so
they all have a in rob schneider
so they have that their that's their
group you know and they're very tight
that's what happens you become very
close friends laugh actually
you're doing stand-up now what can we
expect
well i don't really do characters it's
me and just my sense of humor
and i say you know if you don't uh if
you don't have the ability to laugh at
yourself don't come to the show
let's stand up and make fun of myself
you know it's satire i satirize
everything
you know but it's in good fun and i just
think
you know i don't really have a point to
my accept you know i make fun of
everybody but
my real point is you know everyone's a
person and just treat them with respect
and
you know but i make fun of myself i make
fun of everybody
it's it's very it's a very sophomoric
show i have to say
i'm gonna give you a quick little game
we got like 30 seconds you're doing some
iconic movies i'm going to give you the
tagline
for the movie you're in you tell me the
movie okay okay go ahead they're back in
the saddle
the city suckers yeah i see slickers too
being
evil ain't easy
yeah you know little nikki oh i had one
scene
i wasn't in that last one in that one
this is this was a great movie and the
tagline for this movie is
you're only young once you're in this
movie your character's name was scottie
what was the movie
big yeah big so you know your movies
john levitz
well i know what i've been in yeah thank
you so much john we appreciate you gotta
come back in again thank you
all right john lovitz will be appearing
at the laugh factory every monday
tuesday and wednesday
for the next four to six weeks his
birthday is tomorrow
you can get tickets at thelapfactory.com
and las vegas now will be